20-17 has already seen some great video
game releases with head slide The Legend
of Zelda Bratz of the wild rather than
evil 7 and horizon zero dawn grabbing
the headlines but while the mainstream
gaming media has been focused on picking
apart every minor flaw in Mass Effect
Andromeda there have also been a ton of
great smaller releases that have slipped
through the cracks overshadowed by the
big guns until now grab your controller
and fire up your twitch stream because
here's a look at the best games you've
already missed in 2017 night in the
woods infinite falls night in the woods
is a deep and stylish meandering through
the little things in life with a healthy
dose of musing on the nature of God and
the meaning of human existence it also
explores the boredom of working-class
America while presenting and engaging
mystery and allowing players to explore
minigames and side missions galore and
the beautifully designed dream sequences
filled with fear emptiness and the
search for meaning are not to be missed
[ __ ] in at ten or some hours might in
the woods is one game that shouldn't be
missed
static if you're looking for something a
little different welcome to static a
puzzle solving virtual reality
experience in which you don't know where
you are who you're with or why your
hands are locked inside increasingly
difficult puzzle boxes the puzzles
themselves strike just the right balance
between trickiness and ease well the
atmosphere in which you're tasked with
solving them is downright creepy the
first generation of virtual reality
consoles have been criticized for not
having enough killer games to justify
the cost but innovative and fun
experiences like static are quickly
changing that notion try it and see for
yourself wonder boy the dragon's trap
available for switch and the ps4
wonderboy the dragon's trap is a perfect
example of how to make a 30 year old
game great in 2017 a remake of a 1989
game
when the boy the Dragons trap it's being
revamped with a beautiful and cartoony
art style while retaining the original
platform of story and mechanics as a
bonus the players can even choose to
play the original version instead if
they want which is pretty much the
ultimate in retro gaming the sexy brutal
curves to remain trapped in a
never-ending masquerade ball players and
their sexy brute all have to try to
prevent a series of murders which take
place on a continual time-bending loop
to solve the mystery players must master
the essence of the games time looping
mechanic in addition to flexing their
investigative muscles in ways the
classic board game Clue could only dream
about the sexy blue tile isn't very long
but after you have solved the last
murder you'll be left eating for more
hidden folks take one look at this
game's artistic style and it's
impossible not to be intrigued combining
classic Where's Waldo style hunting fun
with gorgeous hands-on visuals in a
one-of-a-kind gameplay experience it
invokes as perfect for mobile phones
were also being right at home on PC and
Mac the daydream II landscapes are
teeming with activity the Bursar's of
title implies much of it is hidden
inviting me to explore the game to
discover its many secrets the
ORN though once you start playing it's
nearly impossible to stop
so don't boot up hidden folks unless you
have a lot of free time available you're
going to need it type shift if you're
sick of word jumbles crosswords also
don't you don't worry you just found our
new daily obsession in the form of type
shift which gives you columns of letters
you have to arrange into words until
you've used up order letters available
like a cross between boggle and Tetris
it's simple but deceptively difficult
can you spell addictive once you start
playing type shift you'll never have to
make eye contact with other people on
the bus ever again yay
candle man with a unique combination of
art direction and gameplay cameraman has
already made a name for itself as an
innovative indie title every curious
gamer should try out you play a candle
man who can only stay lit for 10 seconds
on his quest for a distant light the
game's mechanics and story plays it the
contrast between darkness and
illumination using the interaction to
traverse a range of obstacles and
environments candle man is one of those
little games that sometimes gets
overshadowed by bigger louder more
in-your-face
titles but this is one game that refuses
to hide its light under a bushel fire up
candle man and let your gaming light
shine hollow Knight if you ever wondered
what Dark Souls would look like if it
were done Metroid style then hollow
Knight is the game for you with
incredible hand-drawn graphics
breathtaking music and innovative sound
effects hollow Knight provides hours of
entertainment as you explore an
environment filled of puzzles or secret
areas and over 30 tough boss battles for
fans of side-scrolling adventure it just
doesn't get any more stylish or fun than
hollow Knight plus there are already
whole communities to vote it to figuring
out the game's rich and the mysterious
law so what are you waiting for get out
there and do whatever it is you're doing
she remembered caterpillars each ring a
hand-drawn art style reminiscent of a
children's book created under the
influence of psychedelic mushrooms this
color based puzzle game investigates the
bonds between parent and child and
unexpected and strange ways a
mind-bending experience with a touch of
creepiness and more than a heap of
weirdness
he remembered caterpillars as worth
checking out for anyone who is looking
for
something a little different detention
set in 1960's taiwan detention
incorporates elements of Taiwanese and
Chinese culture and mythology into a
disturbing experience a PC gamer said is
quote the closest the game has come to
capturing the essence of the original
Silent Hill games and years for most
gamers that should be about all you need
to know to give this one a shot but to
be one just like Silent Hill the tension
is a creepy and sometimes downright
terrifying game that will horn you long
after you've finally sat down the
controller you know what they say in
Taiwan the game finishes you slither
critters there's nothing quite as
exciting as a game that we imagined
gameplay itself little critters does
just that the premise is simple it's fun
to help critters find the exit to the
level but you don't actually control the
critters instead with a swipe of your
finger you can set a screen apart and
then reposition the pieces to form a new
level layout and since different types
of critters of different movement
patterns figuring out the best way to
play God requires a lot of strategy good
luck because those critters are counting
on you blaster master zero taking
players on a retro trip for the golden
days of the Nintendo Entertainment
System blaster master zero is an 8-bit
side-scrolling and top-down
action-adventure game reinventing the
classic 1988 title blaster master this
new addition keeps all the fun of the
originals while updating gameplay with
three decades worth of innovation making
for a familiar yet fresh gameplay
experience that makes us give you with
nostalgic bless torment tides of
numenera most RPGs these days are heavy
on the combat and light on a narrative
tormenta tides of numenera go together
way emphasizing story over collecting
loot resulting in a gain that's closer
to an interactive fantasy novel than
just another hack and slash orc massacre
for old-school RPG enthusiasts who love
nearly infinite dialogue trees or for
fans of the classic choose your own
adventure novels tides of numenera it's
a game you've been waiting for
Robo Rico
afraid of an artificial intelligence
told future want to kill every robot you
see oculus rift owners rejoice because
robo recall is just a robots playing
first-person virtual reality experience
you've been looking for one of the first
games to really show the potential of
the oculus touch controllers Robo recall
features optimized gameplay to
complement beautiful art direction in
one of the best shooting galleries ever
devised so give it a shot no pun
intended tails off for Syria out in
Japan since August of 2016 the acclaimed
RPG Tales of Vesperia finally came
westward in 2017 despite praise from
fans and critics alike though tales of
Masseria has been heavily overshadowed
by more hyped triple-a games
don't let that fool you though with an
unusually dark and mature storyline and
some truly memorable characters Tales of
Vesperia features over 50 hours of
engrossing gameplay plus it allows you
to experience firsthand what it might be
like to live inside an anime world if
there's one thing depan knows how to do
its create incredible RPG adventures so
if you're a fan of the genre or simply
want to find out what all the fuss is
about
give tales of per serie a try you won't
regret it
lead - there seems to be no shortage of
retro inspired pixel art games these
days but don't dismiss bleed to is just
another contra clone with buttery smooth
controls charming pixelated animation
and the boss battles that are truly epic
lead to managers to be accessible to
everyone while still rewarding those who
wish to dive deeper into its intricacies
it's also more forgiving than most
contour inspired games particularly on
lower difficulty levels and can be
completed in roughly two hours so you
really have no excuse not to give this
one a shot pinball fx2
Star Wars pinball rogue 1 pinball fans
will enjoy this game fans of Star Wars
rogue ones will enjoy this game pack
everyone who enjoys fun more like Star
Wars pinball rogue one
it features tight mechanics silky smooth
gameplay and fantastic physics with
sound effects and the movie quotes
galore even casual fans of the film will
appreciate the level of detail and
creative
that have gone into this table whether
it be the Black Death trooper firing
lasers all over the place during a multi
ball or gin giving the smash down to a
storm trooper so are you a pinball
wizard or a pinball Jedi put your
virtual porter in and find out symbol
we'd park if you liked your adventures
to be of the point-and-click variety
look no further than the shore fire
under the radar head then ball we park
it's not just a point-and-click
adventure game mind you
according to polygon director Whitney
Reynolds it's actually a point-and-click
adventure game about point in circuit
adventure games with meta references to
spiritual predecessors like maniac
mansion fans of the genre would have to
be true maniacs Tamaki of this want to
go just don't play it if you're easily
offended you kid with a crappy
wheelchair were you in a past life or
something seriously kid you're in a
wheelchair and you got a face it looks
like that thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you're nothing
[Music]